There are many different types of machine learning
problems, but two common ones are supervised learning and
unsupervised learning. Machine learning typically involves generating some
type of model regarding the problem we're trying to
solve. We'll feed data into this model and
then try to make predictions. In supervised learning, there
are labeled inputs that we train our model
on. Training our model simply means teaching the model
what the answer looks like. So, for example, if we
were detecting spam using supervised learning, we might have 100 emails
where we know whether or not they're spam. We can
use these emails, where we know whether or not the email
is spam, and train a model that can predict whether
or not a future email will be spam based on a
bunch of characteristics, maybe its contents, or whether or not it
has an attachment, or things like that. Another example of supervised
learning would be estimating the cost of a new house,
given that we have a number of examples where we know
about a bunch of features like the square footage, or the
number of rooms, or the location. And we also know how
much that house sold for. We could train a model,
and then predict how much a future house will sell for,
given we know all the same parameters. This is an example
of regression. When performing unsupervised learning, we don't have any such
training examples. Instead we have a bunch of
unlabeled data points, and we're trying to understand the
structure of the data, often by clustering similar data
points together. For example, if we were to feed
an unsupervised learning algorithm a bunch of photos,
it might split the photos into groups, say photos
of people, photos of horses, photos of buildings, without
being told a priori what those groups should be.
It might not know that the groups are people, or horses,
or buildings, but it can tell that these distinct groups exist.